bonjour à tous bienvenue à strasbourg au
parlement européen pour cette dernière
édition de la saison d'europe hebdo dans
cette émission nous allons nous pencher
sur notre santé et celle des 500
millions d'européens
avant de nous intéresser à la question
des perturbateurs endocriniens retour
sur une autre polémique de santé
publique le 29 juin en plein sommet
européen sur le break site la commission
européenne annonce qu'elle va prolonger
de 18 mois l'autorisation d'exploitation
du glyphosate puissant herbicide dont le
célèbre round up de monsanto et provoque
un tollé
retour sur les faits
après des mois d'atermoiements et de
polémiques entre les capitales
européennes la commission a donc pris
ses responsabilités le glyphosate
herbicide controverse et restent
autorisés pour une période de 18 mois
malgré la résistance de plusieurs états
membres le temps on l' agence européenne
des produits chimiques de publier un
avis au plus tard à la fin 2017
une décision qui ne satisfait personne
ni les industriels qui souhaitent une
autorisation d'exploitation initialement
prévue pour 15 ans ni les associations
de défense de la nature et des
consommateurs qui souhaitent une
interdiction immédiate
réuni à plusieurs reprises les
représentants des 28 ne jamais réussi à
trouver un consensus sur la question et
les nombreuses expertises en ajouter à
la cacophonie
si l' agence européenne du médicament
juge le risque cancérogène improbable ce
n'est pas la position de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
depuis plusieurs mois les manifestations
se multiplient face à cette résistance
la france malte l'allemagne l'italie
l'autriche et le portugal se sont
positionnés contre le glyphosate
plusieurs ong
d'ores et déjà les capitales à interdire
sans attendre la substance sur leur
territoire la cacophonie risque donc de
durer 18 mois encore
alors la cacophonie sur le glyphosate le
fameux round up un de monsanto entre
autres va-t-elle encore durer 18 mois
pour en parler je reçois michèle rivasi
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député au sein
de ce parlement europe ecologie les
verts et à côté de vous françoise
grossetête bonjour vous êtes vous membre
du groupe l'est républicain donc ppe
parti populaire européen mesdames vous
connaissez très bien à ces questions de
santé publique
déjà sur la forme je voulais un petit
peu avoir votre avis la décision de
prolonger de 18 mois a été annoncé
rendu public en plein sommet européen
sur le break site
est-ce que c'est pas un peu maladroit de
la part de la commission françoise
grossetête
non je pense qu'il y avait il ya il n'y
a pas eu de majorité qualifiée au sein
du conseil pour prendre une décision
concernant l'autorisation d'utilisation
de ce glyphe aux actes alors dans ce cas
là c'est la commission qui répond et la
commission a besoin certainement y voir
un peu plus clair parce qu'il ya des
positions et des querelles d'experts sur
cette question là donc quand on a des
querelles d'experts bien la meilleure
solution c'est d'accorder une
autorisation sur un délai très court 18
mois on saura très vite en essayant
d'avoir le maximum d'informations d'ici
là pour voir quelles décisions prendre
mais c'est vrai que il y à une plusieurs
conseils qui se sont réunis ou les
ministres ont été incapables de prendre
une décision commune et que les
créateurs de majorité qualifiée est
effectivement cette majorité n'est
jamais sorti cette majorité n'est jamais
sorti et c'est dans ce cas là c'est la
commission qui prend les décisions
donc en fait c'est ça qui nous décision
stabilité des états c'est ça que vous
êtes en train de dire comme les états ne
sont pas mis d'accord ça a été assez
conditions de travail et même souvent
sur ces questions là effectivement les
états membres ont beaucoup de
difficultés à prendre des positions on
l'a vu sur d'autres sujets des gars mais
donc ça ne me surprend pas beaucoup
simplement on a on assiste à un
véritable querelle d'experts sur cette
question du glyphosate
mais je sais que miss elle n'est pas
d'accord
on assiste à une querelle d'experts
parce qu'il y a en plus je pense des
études qui ont été faites mais mais pas
de la même manière
alors on compare ce qui n'est pas
vraiment comparé à ce qu'il faut pour
être clair diallo m s 1 par l'un de ses
laboratoires qui a rendu en fait un avis
comme quoi c'était effectivement
probablement cancérogènes et dans
l'autre sens l'efsa donc l' agence
européenne de la sécurité des aliments a
dit qu'il ne fait pas du tout c'était
totalement un problème que ce soit
improbable pardon que ce soit
cancérogènes vous y croyez ou pas c'est
quoi ces querelles dans même s'il ya une
vraie cacophonie
pour tout vous dire l'organisation
mondiale de la santé a évalué 1500 étude
on les a reçu 6 au parlement européen et
ils ont dit voyez dans ses études il ya
des études qui ont été faites sur les
rats qui montre bien que dufaux zac est
cancérigène
de l'autre côté l'agencé européenne efsa
puisqu'elle était reçu dans le cas de
notre commission on participe tout le
dis on a rendu un avis sur des études
qui sont confidentiels et moi je leur
dis en tant que scientifique comment on
peut rendre un avis sur des études qui
ne peuvent pas et public
alors on nous dit ah mais c'est le savez
le secret d'affaires des laboratoires
qu'ont fait ces études dont celle de la
borat des laboratoires qui produisent en
fait ce qu'il faut at exactement c'est
toujours le widget ariel d'abord un
c'est vous voyez bien qu'ils sont juges
et parties
oui mais que deux en tant que
scientifique on n'est pas accès à ses
études
donc même le commissaire de la santé a
écrit aux industriels pour dire mais les
parlementaires demandent la publicité de
ses études alors on nous a dit vous
pouvez la voir mais il faut aller à
parme en italie ou dans une agence
allemande et vous n'avez pas le droit de
faire des photocopies de prendre des
photos etc et vous avez juste votre
papier crayon
comment voulez-vous que sur quatorze
études on regarde voyez toutes les
données les graphiques etc et que
d'autres scientifiques dépendant puisse
évaluer si oui ou non c'est cancérigène
france dangereusement jeudi que la fia
quand il a donné son avis on ne peut pas
l'accepter parce que on n'a pas accès
aux deux voilà parce que la méthodologie
en fait et pas très clair
main oui mais en plus je dis que les
études sont pas fait de la même manière
c'est à dire soit on fait une étude sur
la substance elle même le glyphosate et
là les résultats des études disent qu
effectivement ce glyphosate la substance
active de ce défaut zac n'est pas n'est
pas cancérogène
mais que par contre il peut être
cancérogène avec des cons formulant
c'est-à-dire associé à d'autres
substances dont des cocktails un effet
cocktail tout à fait donc c'est là qu'il
faut faire la distinction
et c'est vrai qu'avec ces querelles
d'experts il est important d'essayer d'y
voir plus clair et je pense que ces 18
mois sont importants que ça brille ça
paraît dérisoire 18 mois pour rendre un
avis sur un dossier comme celui là non
mais c'est à dire que là ils vont
regarder encore une fois les études
faites par les industriels et j'espère
qu'on aura on aura accès pas c'est une
autre agence qui va le faire c'est les
k1 et elle va faire une étude sur plutôt
l'écotoxicologie puisque eux ils font
regarde et regarde les paramètres
physiques chimiques et écotoxiques hall
et écotoxicologiques donc ils vont
regarder mais vous voyez et moi je pense
que brême grossesse est d'accord avec
moi
il est anormal que notre agence
confinance que l'élève ça donne un avis
sans transparence quand même des données
ce qui est important de dire c'est que
cette autorisation qui est donnée pour
18 mois de plus elle elle est quand même
encadrée par des restrictions c'est à
dire que on accorde cette autorisation
pour usage professionnel d'abord parce
qu'on pense que les professionnels sont
quand même plus informés des dangers et
plus informés des dosages qui sont
autorisés c'est vrai qu'un simple
particulier quand ils utilisent le
roundup
il va pas véritablement contrôler la
candidat l'âge mais le dosage et il va
l'utiliser peut-être dans des conditions
qui sont pas les meilleures conditions
donc là il peut y avoir il faut y avoir
des dangers les agriculteurs peut-être
mais aujourd'hui ils sont de plus en
plus informés les applicateurs humeur
parce que personne et parce que ils
peuvent ils savent qu'il peut y avoir
des conséquences sanitaires
effectivement parce qu'eux aussi ils
payent le produit est que il ya aussi un
intérêt économique elle ne pas surdose
et donc je pense que cette autorisation
bien encadrés pendant ces 18 mois
moi me satisfait plus j'espère que dans
18 mois on aura de nouveau un débat sur
cette substance là mais le plus objectif
possible parce que c'est la plus longue
distance à ce que tous les agriculteurs
se retourne quand même dans une
situation extrêmement compliquée les
agriculteurs n'ont pas de solution
alternative alors justement de faire de
l'agriculture biologique dans certaines
conditions mais de l'agriculture
extensive
justement on a été mesdames à la
rencontre un de ces céréaliers et de ces
agriculteurs qui essaye de faire en
sorte de trouver des alternatives et qui
ont été pris un petit peu au piège de
ces pesticides qui en ont subi les
conséquences c'est marie brémaud qui
nous emmène à la rencontre des
céréaliers
il faisait figure de réussite dans son
métier 240 hectares de céréales en plein
coeur du cher une belle exploitation
agricole et pourtant jean marie a failli
en mourir en 2001 les médecins lui
diagnostiquent un millier laumes un
cancer très agressif de la moelle
osseuse
les médecins du morceau mon mon
pronostic est une espérance de vie de
trois mois très vite l'équipe médicale
lui présente une liste de molécules
qu'il aurait pu manipuler dans le cadre
de son travail
j'ai regardé la liste je ne sais pas la
peine que j'aille en cinq dates en jeu
c'est chlorobenzène la culture dominante
de l'exploitation était le maïs et
l'herbe et celle utilisée était un
herbicides à base de chlore au benzène
et ça j'ai utilisé ça pendant jusque
pratiquement jusqu'à son retrait donc en
2007 la france a été le dernier pays
d'europe on l'a retiré 1 je peux vous
ressortir le photographier des
étiquettes
étant donné la faible toxicité de ce
produit aucune protection de
l'utilisateur nécessaire ça veut dire
que vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
protéger tandis que le produit n'est pas
dangereux pour vous est ce que j'aurais
pu faire autrement
moi j'ai choisi ce métier par vocation
c'est un métier qui me plaisait je
l'exerçais et je me suis imposé
mais certains essayent aujourd'hui de
faire autrement
c'est le cas de denis céréaliers lui
aussi mais dans la beauce il faisait
chaud un samedi mais beaucoup de soleil
la chaleur et j'avais regardé un petit
peu dans les bouquets floraux là je
tapotait simplement comme ça
là il tombe et 15 pucerons c'est lé
chose de phénoménal
donc là il ya danger pour la culture il
ya donc j'ai si j'étais pas intervenue
lé poids il s'arrête à y poussent plus
faut apprendre à gérer faut réfléchir
faut observer et puis voilà les
pesticides ne l'est pas des adeptes du
pesticide on n'aime pas trop ça c'est
quand on peut s'en passer on s'en passe
moi sincèrement si je peux éviter g8 la
par là une utilisée des pesticides mais
pas systématiquement les de manière
proportionnée sur les 125 hectares qui
possède c'est l'apprentissage de denis
avec le soutien de sarah ingénieur
agricole auprès de la chambre
d'agriculture
mais pour lutter contre les mauvaises
herbes
difficile de le faire sont des produits
phytosanitaires des produits que le
céréalier stock ici dans ce local fermé
à clé et aéré voilà donc sa série si le
fond luge utiliser cette année ont
localisé sur le colza ou j'ai réduit de
70% la dose homologuée en quatre ans
denis a réduit d'environ un quart
l'utilisation des pesticides
une tendance générale celui d'un local
comme ça il ya trente produits
commerciaux c'est tout pas plus
tout le monde pense qu'on met des
quantités imaginable de pesticides non
c'est faux il y avait il ya cinq ans à
peu près 1000 produits commerciaux en
france à mener les matières actives
autorisées en france on l à 350
maintenant donc il faut qu'on change
avec toussaint mais diminué ces intrants
est loin d'être une évidence et
l'accompagnement des agriculteurs
restent essentiels la précédent
les attributions des cultures actuelles
enfin qu'ils sont dans les champs c'est
année c'est relativement moyen parce que
vu l'absence d'hiver on a une grosse
pression maladie c'est une démarche
personnelle réduire ces intrants c'est
pas forcément quelque chose qui se fait
naturellement
c'est quand même plus sécurisant de dire
bah voilà je mets le produit qu'il faut
au bon endroit à la quantité qu'il faut
et puis je rentre chez moi je me
couchais tout se passe bien
là on prend plus de risques en donc ça
faut quand même être capable de le faire
je veux dire le physiquement face
écologiquement retour dans le cher avec
jean-marie et chose incroyable
celui ci au volant de son tracteur
continuent d'arroser ses cultures avec
des intrants chimiques huit ans de
combat contre la maladie et trois
greffes de moelle osseuse n'auront pas
suffi à le sevrer des pesticides
désabusé jean marie dresse aujourd'hui
un constat amer on est parti dans cette
logique donc développement effréné de la
deûle à la chimie au service de des
productions agricoles
j'avoue que le fait de produire parce
que notre but c'est de nourrir les gens
certainement pour les imposer à dériver
dans un système catastrophique
catastrophique mais si on veut revenir
en arrière
il faut repenser notre modèle agricole
c'est pas un agriculteur tout seul le
gars dans sa bosse l'hôte sur le plateau
de la marne l'autre dans le département
du cher qui veut qu'ils vont arriver à
changer les choses
le céréalier compte vendre son
exploitation dans les mois prochains
pour donner un coup de main à son fils
qui s'est lancé dans le maraîchage avec
le moins d'intrants possible à 56 ans
pour jean marie cela ressemble fort un
retour à la terre
donc finalement l'alternative c'est de
fonctionner afin d'aller vers le bio
d'aller vers le sens entrant et ça en
fait françoise grossetête
l'exemple est ce qu'on a vu dans votre
reportage c'est très intéressant parce
que finalement on voit qu'il y a bien
sûr l'alternative c'est le bio mais mais
il ya aussi la phase transitoire
c'est l'agriculture raisonnée c'est à
dire petit à petit utiliser le moins
possible d'entrants de pesticides et
pour aboutir à une agriculture qui soit
la plus saine possible
je pense que c'est particulièrement
important ça veut dire qu'on n'est plus
dans cette logique productiviste de la
gloire des années 50 à la sortie de la
deuxième guerre mondiale on on est dans
une nouvelle ère finalement on est dans
une nouvelle ère et vous voyez le
reportage qui le montrait bien il faut
de la formation de l'éducation
on a voulu tellement simplifiée quelque
part est un disque réalisé l'agriculture
que la personne même qu'avait son cancer
eh bien elles continuent elles utilisées
parce qu'elle était dans ce modèle là en
disant si je veux plus de production il
faut que je mette plus d'intrants plus
d'engrais chimiques et plus d'herbicide
plus de fongicides plus de voyez tout ce
qu'on appelle les pesticides est là mais
non sa demande d'observer vous avez vu
là on voyait que la personne a observé
ces cultures pour savoir s'il fallait en
mettre ou pas en mettre et effectivement
maintenant l'agriculteur quand ils
voient que il peut mourir de cancer et
commence à se dire si moi je meurs dans
les produits va y avoir des pesticides
je vais faire mourir les gens c'est
qu'ils vont consommer mais produite elle
revient sur la question des clauzades ça
veut dire que dans 18 mois une fois que
celui ci sera ou pas interdit il faudra
qu'il trouve une alternative parce qu'on
nous dit souvent que il n'y a pas
d'alternative il en existe ou pas il n'y
a pas dans l'immédiat les nouveaux actes
ya pas forcément d'alternative dalton
sauf que l'alternative elle existe si on
change complètement de modèle
ça c'est pas du jour au lendemain et ce
que je voudrais dire quand même quand on
voit ça et que je vois que dans
bordelais oui il ya des écoles qui sont
plein milieu des vignes et que je vois
les agriculteurs qui sont renvoyés de
d'aspergés en quelque sorte leur vie
avec ses produits toxiques
voyez que là il ya un manque de
protection dans ma région la drogue
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans les villes
c'est carrément des épandages aériens or
l'euro a interdit les épandages aériens
et sa cause oui parce qu'il ya des
dérogations qui sont accordées par les
préfets donc là moi je me dis qu'il ya
une urgence
voyez il ya un empoisonnement quelque
part de l'air et puis via l'eau et puis
via aussi toutes les cultures qu'on
consomme donc l'urgence est de dire
vraiment utilise la moins possible c'est
ce qu'on appelle à la culture raisonnée
mais il vaut vraiment le pouvoir le
contrôler et puis changer de modèle
parce que il ya plein d'études qui
montrent que si on se lancent dans le
bio avec une formation parce que c'est
pas le moment ça devient ça ça ne
produisent pas comme ça et bien c'est
long c'est leurrons pas ce qu'il faut ou
trois ans ou 50 ans à cinq ans et c'est
là où les collectivités doivent
accompagner les agriculteurs mais quand
même
après c'est notre santé et tout l'argent
qu'on dépense parce qu'il ya une
épidémie de cancers est bien une des
grosse pause c'est le justement les
pesticides et les perturbateurs
endocriniens que on va aborder
alors justement liaison toute trouvée
merci beaucoup merci à la base'' les
perturbateurs endocriniens c'est aussi
le lot de sujets de controverse en
europe après trois ans d'attentes la
commission a enfin rendu une définition
sur ces substances chimiques
omniprésents dans notre environnement et
notre chaîne alimentaire mais bien
entendu comme d'habitude elle ne
satisfait personne alors si en france on
connaît le bisphénol a qui a été
interdite autour de nous les
perturbateurs endocriniens sont bien
plus nombreux direction la suède pays en
pointe sur ces recherches avec flora
sauvage
ils sont partout dans des produits de la
vie courante bisphénol a phtalates
parabènes les perturbateurs endocriniens
sont des substances chimiques qui
agissent sur notre système hormonal
il serait à l'origine de cancers de
diabète de type 2 de problèmes
cardiovasculaires mais aussi
d'infertilité à renée jeanne trotte
travail à la mairie de stockholm il est
en charge de l'élimination de ces
produits toxiques de la vie des
habitants
ça ça marche quand voici l'un des objets
de la vie courante le plus commun de
tous
un ballon gonflable pour la plage on
peut sentir l'odeur du phtalate dans le
plastique le pvc
c'est une odeur très reconnaissable il
peut y avoir aussi des phtalates sur les
imprimés des t-shirts comme sur celui ci
t shirts se déjoue également et puis
voici une boîte de conserve dans
laquelle il y a de l'époxy qui contient
du bisphénol
si en europe il n'ya pas de
réglementation stricte sur ces produits
chimiques
en suède on préfère appliquer le
principe de précaution
oui après ça nous avons mis en place une
série d'outils pour aider les
responsables de la ville de stockholm à
faire les bons choix lorsqu'il s'agit de
se procurer des matériaux de
construction
mais nous avons aussi mis en place des
programmes d'information pour éduquer
nos agents afin de les aider à utiliser
des produits qui ne contiennent pas de
perturbateur endocrinien ou des
substances
la suède est en pointe depuis des années
sur la question des perturbateurs
endocriniens à l'université d'uppsala
cécile à bergues études il en a path est
aussi nommé dans les stats c'est au
milieu des années 90 que l'expression
perturbateurs endocriniens a commencé à
être utilisée ainsi mon laboratoire
s'est impliqué dans la recherche dans ce
domaine car on a remarqué qu'il y avait
des semelles phoque dans la merde
qui était devenue stérile elle ne
parvenait plus à se reproduire et elle
avait des problèmes au niveau des
glandes surrénales et tout ceci était en
lien avec la pollution environnementale
donc les perturbateurs endocriniens sont
un sujet d'étude depuis longtemps cécile
à bergues a choisi d'étudier les
grenouilles
car leur système hormonal est similaire
à celui des humains sa poche semaine au
cours de nos recherches nous avons
découvert que les têtards qui nage dans
une eau avec une faible concentration
d'oestrogènes la même substance qui se
trouvent dans les pilules contraceptives
bien il change de sexe les mâles
développe des ovaires au lieu des
testicules
mais qu'en est il des perturbateurs
endocriniens sur le système hormonal des
êtres humains à l'hôpital pour enfants
de stockholm
on constate une augmentation du nombre
de bébés qui naissent avec une
malformation du pénis
autre chiffre inquiétant la production
de spermatozoïdes a baissé de plus de
40% chez l'homme en europe sur les 50
dernières années au les odeurs et
endocrinologue
il met en garde contre l'effet cocktail
de certaines substances chimiques
additionnées les unes aux autres non
certains de ces phtalates sont bien
connus pour leurs effets toxiques sur le
système hormonal et lille ont été
interdits mieux mais d'autres talent at
on vu le jour et nous ne savons pas les
effets qu'ils peuvent avoir car ils
n'ont pas encore fait l'objet d'études
et d'enlever les nord du lac
ce qui est certain c'est que les humains
ne sont pas entouré d'un seul phtalates
mais d'un cocktail de substances en 2013
la commission européenne a commencé à
dresser une liste de critères des
perturbateurs endocriniens
mais sous le poids des lobbys elle a
lancé une étude d'impact qui a ralenti
le processus
devant la lenteur de la commission la
suède a déposé un recours auprès du
tribunal de l'union européenne
finalement en juin 2016 la commission a
établi
liste de critères mais elle est loin de
satisfaire les défenseurs de
l'environnement
nous voulions que la commission
européenne établissent sans plus
attendre des critères scientifiques pour
identifier les perturbateurs
endocriniens
nous voulions que ces critères soient
strictement scientifique ce qui voulait
dire qu'il ne fallait pas que soit prise
en compte d'autres éléments comme des
études d'impact car nous savons grâce à
la science que même avec une quantité
infime un produit chimique peut avoir un
effet très important sur le système
hormonal facts about the la proposition
de critères des perturbateurs
endocriniens établi par la commission
doit encore être validé par les états
membres puis par le parlement européen
mais cette liste ne satisfait personne
alors objectivement c'est quand même pas
très claire alors cette définition
qu'est ce qu'elle dit de la définition
de la commission européenne ces critères
pourquoi est-ce que personne n'est
satisfait ouais enfin vaste jamais
écouté c'est incroyable quand même cette
histoire c'est une vraie saga habitants
oui ma soeur la direction générale de
l'environnement avait établit les
critères et vous savez que la commission
elle voulait pas établir les critères
vous voulez faire une étude d'impact
économique l'air comme les salles et
coutu à l'industriel suivant des
critères qu'on allait faire oui donc et
on a dit mais nous on veut les critères
donc on a saisi la cour de justice dans
cette affaire incroyable de mettre une
étude d'impact économique dans une
définition mérite et la cour de justice
européenne a dit mais c'est pas votre
rôle de faire une étude d'impact vous
c'est les critères tel que l'avait
défini les parlementaires et puis là
dessus nous sortent des critères en
disant on va prendre les critères de
l'om est donc au doux nom du très bien
et prendre les critères de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
sauf que au lieu de dire que c'est un
perturbateur endocrinien qui va
entraîner des effets secondaires sur un
organisme vivant sur sa progéniture et
sur sa population ait dit ça va
entraîner des effets secondaires
seulement sur les humains et donc si
vous faites les humains il ya très peu
d'études faites sur les humains toutes
les études sont sains pour les animaux
et donc quand on a regardé leurs
critères et bien même des scientifiques
disent eh ben on va supprimer peut-être
une molécule comme le distilbène et tous
les autres et en plus deuxième chose ils
nous disent on prend plus l'étude de
dangers c'est à dire est ce que oui ou
non c'est un perturbateur endocrinien et
à ce moment là on va le substitut et
l'éliminer ou faire en sorte à trouver
d'autres molécules voiliers qui sont pas
perturbateurs endocriniens
ils disent on va choisir le risque ou
l'exposition ce qui est complètement en
dehors du traité de lisbonne moyen du
principe de précaution
donc on est vent debout extrêmement
subtile enfin et c'est le citoyen c'est
très subtil effectivement pour le
citoyen lambda y compris pour nous tout
simplement
la commission européenne nous diminuons
justement elle nous avons ces arguments
qui ne tiennent pas
mais essayer de créer un peu un
brouillard mais ce dont milliards est
clair on sait à quel point est souvent
ça a été pointé la commission européenne
peut parfois prêter le flanc à des
lobbys industriels qui souvent vont
taper à sa porte et fait en sorte que
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure sur
l'étude d'impact économique
on essaye de concilier un petit peu la
chèvre et le jour mais là c'est qu'on
est là de relégation et là dedans on a
eu les preuves en substituant des mails
à la commission que l'industrie chimique
avait demandé à la commission de faire
cette étude d'impact et là qu'on en veut
aux commissaires de la santé pourquoi on
en veut à monsieur juncker qui est
président de la commission c'est qu'en
ce moment ils sont pas en train de
protéger la santé
ils sont en train de protéger le
business et donc nous on dit les
parlementaires là on est assez uni en
disant m'attendais le rôle de la
commission
c'est avec ce qu'a demandé le parlement
de protéger la santé des citoyens
européens
là vous ne le faites pas vous êtes en
train de protéger l'industrie chimique
et regarder les épidémie de cancer
pendant les épidémies d'obésité de
diabètes d'affairé lié à ça mais bien
sûr c'est qu'ils ont perdu entre autres
oui alors c'est vrai qu'il faut il faut
pas non plus bannir systématiquement
toute politique industrielle
nous avons besoin dès lundi parce que
nous avons besoin de nos emplois et
l'industrie évolue sans cesse avec des
nouvelles technologies sait on n'est pas
contre moi je ne suis pas dit les
parents du centre l'entreposage de
précaution tous les mains surtout pas
parce que ce serait grave
on peut pas opposés l'un à l'autre mais
il faut trouver cet équilibre mais
dedans quand il s'agit de perturbateur
endocrinien
willy a vraiment des conséquences sur la
fertilité de la population et avec
d'autres risques liés à la santé
à ce moment là on a vraiment de quoi
s'interroger et dire attention quand on
a la certitude que telle substance est
perturbateur endocrinien
à ce moment-là endocrinien à ce moment
là il faut véritablement prendre les
bonnes décisions et puis il ya quelque
chose de particulier les perturbateurs
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de seuil
voyez une femme enceinte par exemple on
s'est aperçu que c'est à des doses très
faibles que ça peut avoir une
conséquence sur le foetus donc ça veut
dire que dans son environnement
il faut éliminer c'est pour ça que les
critères sont importants éliminer les
perturbateurs qui a dans les peintures
qui a par exemple dans la moquette qui a
par exemple dans les rideaux qui a dans
les cosmétiques on se met sur la peau il
ya dans notre alimentation via les
pesticides s'il ya beaucoup de
pesticides et je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte sur un millier par exemple
de perturbateurs endocriniens qui a dans
notre environnement et bien suivant les
options qu'a choisi la commission il y
en aurait soit 35 qui serait éliminé
voyez sur les 445 qui ont été évalués et
avec les options terrible qui nous
proposent ils n'auraient même pas deux
donc vous voyez que quelque part et s'il
y en a que deux éliminés avec tout le
processus qu'on a fait mais enfin il se
fout de notre part mais laissez moi j'en
suis furieux doigt vers la coalition
parce que je défends tellement l'europe
voyez pour la protection des citoyens
européens que l' effet là je me rends tu
la commission elle te passe de déficit
démocratique on est un petit peu là de
bien écouter
merci beaucoup mesdames on suivra donc à
partir du mois de septembre
cette actualité merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi et on me dit que vous êtes
de plus en plus nombreux c'était donc la
dernière émission de cette saison bel
été à vous on se retrouve à la rentrée
au mois d'octobre pour suivre bien
entendu cette actualité européenne qui
s'annonce une fois de plus foisonnante
merci aux journalistes qui nous aident
chaque semaine à préparer cette émission
aux équipes techniques qui la réalise au
stagiaire nombreux qui sont passés par
nos rédactions et bien entendu à vous de
nous suivre
à très vite et bel été sur les chaînes
parlementaires à bientôt